[Music]
gal gadot Olivia culpo and more we're
running down the best dressed celebs of
the week with all the details on what
they wore and how much it cost
first up gal at the Justice League
premiere in Los Angeles on Monday
honestly the thing is everything that
happened to that happens that is
happening right now it's so overwhelming
32 year old channel 2 her inner Wonder
Woman in the shimmering sequined gown by
Elsa Zara it's not for sale but will
retail for nine thousand nine hundred
and ninety five bucks
the actress went with jewels by Jennifer
Fisher the ear cuff goes for around two
hundred while her ring is about 225 Jean
completed the look with Christian
Louboutin heels around 400 bucks I mean
all the way from Russia and Israel to
hear red carpet stuck into you wearing
that it's like that it's been such an
amazing crazy ride up next Jessica Biel
turning heads in head to toe lavender at
an NBC press event on Monday thank you /
Zuhair Murad jumpsuit is from the
fashion house's spring summer 2017
ready-to-wear collection on retails for
just over three thousand dollars the
matching headband by Jennifer bear goes
for a one hundred and forty-two bucks
and her Christian Louboutin heels go for
675 finally check out Olivia culpo at an
H FBA an InStyle bash on Tuesday the
microwave confirm a pair she looks like
a chic princess in this black tulle
dress with sheer sleeves and gold
embroidery it's by Monique Lhullier but
the price isn't to get listed her heels
by Francesca Russo would cost you five
hundred and twenty bucks the gold bag is
Judith Leiber worth nineteen hundred
dollars and those earrings by you but
retail for 4,100 bucks
[Music]
you
[Music]